[Musique]
pour aujourd'hui les pauvres ont le
sentiment de devenir encore plus pauvres
guillaume bigot la l1 la baisse d'impôts
en tout cas des incitations du
gouvernement sont plutôt en faveur des
classes moyennes c'est c'est quoi c'est
inciter les classes qui travaillent
aujourd'hui les français qui travaillent
et qui veillent donc des impôts
enfin les principales baisses d'impôts
ont concerné quand même elles ont
démarré au début du quinquennat
d'emmanuel bacon ont concerné quand même
l'impôt sur la fortune et bien sûr donc
ça ça y est relativement peu d'effet
d'une part d'autres dispositifs de type
a été mesurée et qui d'un port au pardon
les retombées dans celle ci on a mis au
jour ils ont même leur retour le retour
des exilés fiscaux
ça a été ça c'est ça c'est ça a baissé
de 25% à peu près autour des baisers des
exilés fiscaux ils sont pas ils sont pas
revenus massivement fabien et moi que
son parti y en a moins 25% de moins
qu'ils aient une partie et ça mais ils
on va continuer quand même à partir mais
en moins beaucoup à un rythme moins
important
en fait cette mairie de base et
supprimer vous le savez bien sûr les
remplacent la sueur elle a été renforcée
mais en réalité c'est un peu moins de
cadeaux pour les pour région avait du
bruit mais il y en aura encore
c'est bien pour lui pour ceux qui sont
les plus imposés en france
enfin des dispositifs type le crédit
crédit d'impôt pour les entreprises a eu
relativement peu d'effet et peu d'impact
en termes de création d'emplois donc je
peux enfin l'effet prix dont parle mon
voisin avec une baisse de charge une
baisse d'impôts ça améliorerait la
compétitivité de nos entreprises
moi je veux bien mais il y aurait un
effet plus massive parce que c'était
bien attendez il ya un effet beaucoup
plus massif que ça on pourrait obtenir
le même résultat si vous jouez sur la
monnaie et là on en revient
effectivement au coup de main au coût de
passe passe au tour de passe passe assez
sournois que nous joue l'allemagne
depuis qu'il ya l'euro puisque grâce à
l'euro en fait il faut bien comprendre
que l'allemagne qui aura une monnaie
beaucoup plus forte il y avait encore un
deutschemark amorti la hausse de sa
monnaie sur les économies à faible
productivité
donc c'est à coups de chômeurs allemands
et grecs pardon français et grec que les
allemands peuvent avoir une monnaie
relativement compétitifs grâce à nous
heureusement ceaurriz voilà
[Musique]